what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so Justice League of America rebirth is
man the stories also I mean I don't know
if I'd say it's the best thing come out
of DC rebirth right now it's a pretty
strong contender for yes it's a pretty
strong contender in terms of where it
stands the reason why is because this is
kind of like a throwback to Justice
League International that's why I work
so I work so well those are guys who
don't know a little bit of a little bit
of a journey back in time here with
crisis on the Senators DC it kind of
looked around you know with the
post-crisis landscapes figuring out what
it is that they wanted to do and they
want to sort of change it up the status
quo that went for a lot of characters it
was returning Superman back to being the
sole survivor of Krypton it was you know
taking taking Green Lantern back to his
roots it was browning Batman you know
making it more dark more brooding that
was really the way it was for a lot of
these characters but with regards to the
Justice League it was effectively
disbanded what we got in this place was
Justice League International and Justice
League International was basically a
Batman led Justice League team with
people who normally would never have
been able to hold their own Congress Guy
Gardner and different guys like that guy
Gardner's popularity increased because
of Justice League International but at
the time he was considered to be a
character who just couldn't hold his own
publication now Justice League
International at the outset was wildly
popular just because of the fact that
there was a lot of like you know arguing
and bickering especially between Batman
and Guy Gardner because they had such
stubborn personality than each each one
thought that they were right but Batman
was the de facto leader and so what just
Justice League International did it
actually spot out you know several
titles but eventually Justice League of
America was returned to its normal
status in 1998 with JLA by Grant
Morrison now what this does is kind of
give us a sort of return to familiarity
with Batman's own Justice League team
but remember at the end of Justice
League versus Suicide Squad the basis
behind this was that Batman wanted to
form his own team for reasons that
weren't initially explained but we
should kind of point to the idea of
really DC Universe rebirth when Wally
West shows back up again Batman
recognizes who he is and Wally West
basically tells him about the button
about the Watchmen button Batman has
been working in the background to try to
figure out what's going on with his foot
and grant it has really been taking
place off panel but what Justice League
of America rebirth does is show us the
steps that Batman is taking to basically
set things in the works to deal with
whatever the button is because remember
Batman is a man of caution that man is
the man that always plans ahead and so
the formation of Justice League of
America rebirth at least as far as I'm
aware you know as far as we know right
now has really been done by
man for the purpose of insurance that if
there is some kind of nefarious foe out
there that intends to do the DC Universe
harm that he'll have a justice free team
of his own to basically face off against
them this is compounded by the fact that
the Justice League was taken over by
Maxwell Lord and the Justice League
versus Suicide Squad tie and so it's
really just kind of like a backup team
in case the main Justice League team is
compromised just again a matter of
safety nets a matter of checks and
balances and the realm of Batman but
killer frost was really his first
recruit and the reason why is because
killer frost saved everybody's life at
the end of Justice League versus Suicide
Squad and so because that Batman
basically sat down and said look sure
she was a villain at one point in time
but if she's done anything here is
basically show people that she could be
a good person and she can be a good
person the seeds are there all they have
to do is be nurtured correctly and
that's what he's intending to do here
now at this point to basically switch
over to Black Canary and of course it's
kind of funny to see Black Canary a
killer frost going at it with each other
because from what we gather killer frost
had basically shown up here with the
intention of recruiting Black Canary a
black Canary just freaked and just
started attacking her which is actually
going to play the seed of you know
fighting one another it was kind of a
mistaken set of circumstances but again
it's a little bit of back and forth and
it's basically this idea that not
everybody looks at killer frost or the
person was turned over a new leaf when
they see her they immediately see a bad
guy they immediately see a villain and
rightfully so because of the things that
she's done over the course of her career
with superpowers but again she basically
kind of you know brings the brezza fly
to a halt basically stops and says I'm
here because of him I'm here with that
man now the cool thing about this is
that Black Canary
isn't really a tried and true villain
per se I mean she was really part of
your back girls birds of prey but Batman
connection with Black Canary through
Barbara Gordon and her birds of prey has
really Illustrated the Batman the Black
Canary is somebody they could keep them
all grounded and that's what he's
shooting for the the Justice League of
America team is really kind of like a
mixed bag of you know good guys and bad
guys you know but it's really more
composed of like top hitting people that
it is people who are just kind of new or
just kind of sprung at least initially
that seems to be the case but as will
progress will actually find out Batman
is going to roll in some relatively
fresh faces but Black Canary is is
really like a no-nonsense woman the way
that she's written in DC Comics she
pulls no punches
she tells things how they are and Batman
says you will help to keep us honest you
will help to keep us grounded even if
you're telling us things that we don't
here now of course at this point we
transition over to the main man that's
one of the coolest things about this we
transition over to Lobo and the cool
thing about this is that black Canary's
giving Lobo run for his money I mean
she's not really beaten the absolute
hell out of them for so much and she's
basically establishing or dominance a
little bit of a reverse psychology
because remember Lobo is kind of a man
unto himself
right like Lobo kind of does his own
thing he just kind of out there doing
his own thing now remember lovo exists
here because DC basically ret condom in
DC said that Lobo was part of Suicide
Squad
zero he was part of the Suicide Squad
that we never knew about but because of
the time to their mission went awry
because they basically turned against
the orders of Amanda Waller they were
brought back in again and they were
basically held in stasis they were just
isolated from the world which is why we
never saw the original version of Lobo
in the new 52 we just saw that weird new
52 Lobo that nobody really liked so what
we end up doing is they basically have
like an area saying look I imagine that
you probably wouldn't even be interested
in joining a team like this would you
like you'll really have what it takes to
be part of a team like you don't really
have any gumption like you're just big
talk and again it's just kind of messing
with Lobo but keep in mind what was
about a fool like Lobo knows what's
going on and even if only for the sake
of curiosity he basically allows like an
area two-player game he kind of allows
her to go through the motions it's okay
for us we'll see what's going on other
reason why is because I imagine after
spending so much time in spaces so much
time in isolation really Lobo has a
desire to experience some measure of
belonging and that's one of the cool
things about it was what was a pretty
violent guy he loves tearing stuff up
the guys they are really really cool but
it's deal just like anybody else in
existence Lobo needs somewhere to belong
of course he doesn't feel like you
belong in his own race of people which
is why he killed them all but he still
kind of feels like he needs somewhere to
belong at least that's really the only
explanation I can offer here either that
or Lobo sits down like curious which I
guess was just as possible as anything
else but from here we switch over to a
young guy named Ryan Troy gradually is
basically a stand-in for the Adam Ray
Palmer the reason why is because during
the Adam one-shot there was part of this
lead-up to the release of Justice League
of America rebirth Ryan it basically
become the lab assistant of Ray Palmer
and Ray Palmer basically revealed to
Ryan that Ray himself was the Adam he
was a super hero the issue here is that
the Adam had basically discovered some
kind of fundamental flaw or some
screw-up with a time scape and
discovered what amounts to the
Microverse extremely small universe
within the main DC universe what do you
want to go investigate
he basically disappeared he left a video
recording behind you know that he had
made before he took off to the
microburst and basically tasked Ryan
with harnessing his belt and using it
for the purpose of finding Ray Palmer or
at least some variation of a Palmer's
belt using him for the purpose of
finding ray and bringing him back and so
what this does is really kind of exist
in the in-between you know between these
moments where Ryan had basically been
given this task and when he actually
carries it out but he's basically met by
Batman and in lobo now of course
Batman's idea is to find ray Palmer it's
applying the actual Adams himself so the
reason why is because the Adams a wildly
capable guy he's definitely someone you
won on your side
through his intelligence through his
different abilities and so on and so
forth the issue is they're kind of stuck
with Ryan at the moment the cool thing
about this is that Ryan's very green
around the ears he's very new he's
somebody who can be molded he's
basically a clean slate and so Batman
could basically kind of transform Ryan
into somebody that could really be more
adaptive and more capable to the team or
more conducive to the team as opposed to
to Ray Palmer who would show up with his
existing beliefs his existing views so
on and so forth what he believes being a
superhero is about possibly create a
source of contention so it's really just
kind of a smart move by Batman but at
this point we switch over to a guy named
Raymond now Raymond Terrell or Terrell
or Harvard as you want to pronounce it
it's actually a really really old
character with regards to DC without
really all these 1990s tickets legend
honey - to be specific but with regards
to the DC landscape post new 52 as far
as I'm aware he hadn't shown up there
but what DC rebirths does is it
basically kind of brings him back for
the 90s that says okay a story of
Raymond is a little bit different but in
terms of what he's capable of it's still
very much the same the origin story that
was given to us initially in his own
one-shot which I think comic story
actually has that video up is the reign
was basically a kid just spent his
entire life in the dark the reason why
was because it was discovered at a very
early age that he could absorb light
energy and use it for different purposes
the problem is that he couldn't control
it he had injured people around him and
so being kept in the dark was really his
mom's response to keeping him isolated
to making sure that his powers don't run
a lot now what is up happening of course
is like any teenager it basically
escapes to see the outside world he was
exposed to light and then disappeared
when invisible for four years now
eventually here iam it to stop it you
know stop a some crazy guy from trying
to attack the mayor at the time but from
that point going forward
Raymond basically operated as the way
which is kind of like a community dubbed
in name it
given to him somebody that could
basically manipulate a manipulate light
energy for a multitude of such energy
projection hard light constructs that
kind of a thing so he's really really
powerful in terms of his ability to
promise he's still relatively new to all
this and stuff meeting Ryan Choi the
person who's butts to recruit him Batman
tasks Ryan because of the fact that
Ryan's a new guy and so it would be it
would make more sense to have a new guy
show up as opposed to somebody who might
be intimidating like Batman or somebody
who would be likely to screw things up
like Lobo or Black Canary would be havoc
trying to punch the brain mate of
assuming that you made a pass at or
something along those lines but again at
this point we switch over to the vixen
and this is really the last character
that we get who is being introduced into
the end of the Justice League of America
now vixen is actually a really cool
character the reason why is because
she's able to tap into what's called the
red now the red and the green were
relatively new constructs rosalie new
concepts prior to this you just have
like Swamp Thing you just have a poison
ivy and there were just characters who
were out there but what ended up
happening I want to say was Jeff Lemire
but I'm not going to swear to that but
what ended up happening is the red and
the green are basically created they
were you know designed for the purpose
of basically explaining how it is of
swampthing in poison ivy we're able to
do the things that they do and they're
basically elementals they're able to tap
into all plant life the red allows
people to tap into animal life so if an
animal existed on the face of the planet
Earth its essence what it is continues
to live on within the red and it allows
people who can tap into the red to use
those different things so for example in
this instance vixen is tapping into the
red by way of a bat which allows her the
ability to fly it grants her
echolocation if you were to tap into
like a rhinoceros
she would have the durability of a
rhinoceros if she would have happened to
an elephant she'd have the strength of
an elephant just the other said it's
just different aspects of animals that
are used by individuals who can tap into
the red now of course really with Batman
kind of going to her she's an essential
part of the team and the reason why is
because anybody or any organism that
ever existed on the face of the earth
whether it's extinct or not can be
tapped into by some water can be used by
someone who can tap into the red and so
victim is formidable in terms of her
capabilities at the same time she's very
straightforward she's very honest she
could be one of these people who could
basically be the backbone of the team
and that's why Batman says there is no
team without you because you will be the
backbone you'll be the one that kind of
holds things together in case they begin
to go awry so of course he's able to
grab her bring her
on board and it's really kind of funny
because as soon as we transition to the
Justice League of America headquarters
we have Lobo basically saying welcome to
the Hall of lowered expectation which is
kind of funny but I think this is also
you know Steve Orlando kind of doing a
play on words because I imagine a lot of
people probably didn't really look at
the Justice League of America team as
something that was that was important I
mean Justice League International was a
lot of the same way but people used to
look at JLA people would look at the JLA
concept and say this is a poor man's
justice week this is just this is the
Kmart Justice League you know which I
guess is not really I mean it's not
really true to be honest and it's still
a team in and of itself but the idea
here is that is that I'm basically
coming together and saying look there
are threats that are going to come here
and when those threats are going to
impact earth what people need is the
ability to rally around humans not gods
not Superman Mount Kings of Atlantis you
know not Green Lantern's baiting human
beings tangible things people that they
could say that person's just like me
except maybe they've got some powers
best Batman's aim here and that's what
he says we are basically going to
inspire people you know we're going to
inspire humanity we're going to be the
good guys we're going to work through
inspiring people to view something
better you know as opposed to simply
looking up to us as gods and so on and
so forth not of course that might also
kind of playing both sides because he is
still on the Justice League so I mean
he's being smart about it you know but
again it's really kind of his own
scheming this is basically DC setting
the stage for building things up and
that's what I hope you guys are noticing
when it comes to the DC Universe is
they're building things up the Green
Lantern Corps is expanding numbers are
being built ranks are being expanded and
the idea that somewhere down the line
we'll probably going to see this massive
battle that takes place and we're going
to need as many superheroes as we could
possibly get together in order to face
off against whatever that threat may be
dr. Manhattan or mr. Oz or what have you
but if you guys are new here to come to
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the wrong
course if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all in please
[Music]